talked about good molecules nothing to
hide ingredient lists being performative
transparency before and here is the
latest example their Sheer Mineral
sunscreen contains zinc oxide but also
five percent butylophilate which works
as a chemical sunscreen it's a very
slightly modified version of octa-salate
that protects against UV in exactly the
same way it's basically off to Salette
with slightly longer hair the reason
brands use this instead of transparently
using OCTA salad is that most people
don't realize that they are basically
the same thing so Brands can get away
with calling it a pure mineral sunscreen
even though it's really a hybrid
sunscreen and good molecules has been
posting ads saying it has 100 mineral
filters and that mineral sunscreens are
better than chemical sunscreens which
isn't true and contributes to this
situation where Brands feel like they
need to hide their chemical sunscreens
this is why the transparency is
performative they're giving people extra
info they don't really understand while
being misleading with the obvious stuff